[Music]
so welcome everyone thanks for coming so
today I'm extremely excited to be
introducing introducing Cynthia Brazil
from MIT where she's the director of the
personal robots group at the Media Lab
Cynthia is one of the pioneers of the
field of human robot interaction and she
literally wrote the book on social
robotics Cynthia is also the founder and
chief experience officer of G Bo really
the first social robot for the home that
is an actual working consumer robot and
it's a real success story for moving HRI
out of the lab and into the real world
with with real people
geebo even made the cover of cover of
Time magazine's 2017 issue on the 25
best inventions of the year she is a
long long list of other awards and
achievements over the years with
recognition by the National Academy of
Engineering as well as the National
Design Awards but rather than list a
whole bunch more of these awards I'll go
ahead and hand it over to Cynthia thank
you alright well it's a pleasure to be
here I've had such a great visit seeing
old friends and meeting new friends and
talking about living with AI and robots
so you know I started this work in
social robots I won't tell you how long
ago it was a long time ago
but the thing that is so striking to me
right now
it's just who is living and interacting
with AI today as part of our daily lives
I mean even you know fairly recently
like with but 2014 when Alexa was
announced in December there's like 43
million of these smart speakers in
people's homes now and with that again a
profound shift in who is interacting
with AI and just acknowledging there is
so much opportunity and so much we still
have yet to understand about what it is
to live with intelligent machines when
you think about the diversity of users
from young children to our oldest
seniors and everyone in between and I
think quite a lot about the home in
particular you know I I'm sure you've
all kind of heard the the media quips of
people like oh the future is going to be
like the Starship Enterprise and
have this you know disembodied voice
computer this computer that and for me
you know it's like the home is a special
place it's I don't want it to feel like
work I don't want it to feel like I'm on
the subway it requires I think different
kind of ways of thinking about the
design and how you fit an AI technology
into the place that is in so many ways
your most intimate important place it's
a place where you people who you love
live that really makes me also think
quite a lot about our future with living
with with these AI systems and what this
is going to mean in the in in these very
important spaces like the home and we
know it's not fraught with without
important issues right so this news
article was very striking to me when it
came out 2017 so as you may recall
Mattel was going to basically create an
Alexa like talking speaker for the home
really catering towards not only young
parents being able to reorder diapers
and things like that but interacting
with kids directly and it went very far
down the product development pipeline it
was about to be released for Christmas
and they pulled the product because
there were just a lot of concerns
expressed not because of things that
they knew were bad about this technology
but just we didn't know right we didn't
know so child advocacy groups concerns
around privacy law maker as parents
again we just kind of speaks to the time
right so we just have to be very mindful
about bringing these technologies into
home and appreciating that as
researchers and scientists there's
there's so much more to creating these
technologies that we have to be aware of
so you know today we have these smart
speakers I would say in general a lot of
AI it is designed to be very
transactional in nature it's very much
like an intelligent tool to help you
make decisions but that's quite
different from kind of the vision that I
grew up with you know so growing up with
Star Wars and thinking about these
intelligent machines not just as digital
assistants but really as these kind of
sidekicks and these these helpful
companions that were just useful but
really connected to us on this human
love
and they not only helped us do useful
things that matter to us they actually
even helped us become the people who we
aspire to be right and that was really
the vision that I've grown up with of
what this technology could mean to us
and the exciting thing is now these
technologies are starting to come in to
world world environments we've brought
them into schools looking at robots as
language learning companions into
Hospital Pediatrics to work with Tri
Life specialists to assisted living
facilities and now of course they're
finally coming into the home so again
what's the evolution of AI in the home
is it going to be from this sort of
transactional AI that we have right now
and digital assistants will it become
the sort of different vision of this
helpful companion that's a much more
kind of humanistic design I think the
crux of the matter is again especially
when you talk about robots now we still
understand very much about this
long-term interaction right when talk
about a research setting it is hard
expensive logistically challenging work
to deploy these systems in the real
world into real environments where
they're interacting with real people
where you're innovating on the
algorithms and the capabilities as well
as trying to understand what's the
impact of benefit of these technologies
on real people's lives so this is just a
paper it was a written into 2013 we
actually did an updated version of this
looking at all the longitudinals human
robot interaction studies ever done many
of them were basically not even
innovating on the algorithms just taking
a commercial product like you know a
plio or whatnot into the environment and
just looking to see what people did over
time and the punchline is there's just
not a whole lot of studies out there so
there was a real need for this kind of
work and there's a real need I think for
coupling this with the algorithmic
innovation we need better tools we need
better processes to really help
galvanize and empower of the field to to
advances for it and you know when I
think about AI in the big picture right
again there's a lot of discussion around
productivity and efficiency the future
of work but I feel that the promise AFA
I will not achieve its full potential if
it can't address these very deep human
needs so you know I asked
question and a lot of my work can AI
actually help us to flourish not just to
be more productive but to live better
quality lives and to be better people
and when you look at kind of
operationalized frameworks around things
like well-being it's very clear that
that goes way beyond the cognitive right
you have to think about the social the
emotional the sense of achievement and
meaning if we're going to create a ice
that helped us to live better quality
lives we have to create a eyes that can
engage in support us on all of these
dimensions and I would say although
there's a lot of work on the cognitive
the social-emotional is relatively very
understudied what we are starting to
find out is as you create these social
robots it's not as if they're like like
people who you're going to replace
people or like other kinds of tools like
smart devices they're kind of this new
amalgam of relationships that we kind of
understand but in this new kind of
intersection right so there are
attributes of these systems that engage
you like a motivating collaborative Ally
and I think that's really important
there are aspects of course of a robot
that can be an Internet cloud connected
tool like any other kind of computing
device that's kind of like a given but
the other thing that's fascinating is
the way people naturally seem to want to
relate to it as an other where there's
these attributes of being like an
attentive companion animal the sort of
non-judgmental affectionate and I think
you could appreciate in that video I
just showed you the nature of how people
interact with this technology is very
different than a tablet or a computer or
VR headset it is this social emotional
relational connected other experience
and that actually can be very empowering
for people if designed in the right way
so you know in the top I'm gonna
highlight you know this I think kind of
the punchline of a lot of the work that
I have done so whether we're talking
about a social robot or I think any
other kind of technology that's trying
to support human flourishing is the more
you can support people on all of these
dimensions we as human beings are
clearly not purely cognitive creatures
right we're deeply social deeply and Moe
deeply physical creatures all of these
things influence how we learn how we
make decisions how we perceive the world
around us how are influenced by events
around us but the more you can support
and engage people in this holistic way
what we find is the more deeply people
will invest in that interaction and when
people invest more deeply they can often
be more successful and I think that's
the punchline is they can be even more
successful with the technology than if
you don't designed to support this
holistic experience so I want to talk
about this is kind of touching a little
mix of research and application of kind
of what is different about this
experience with this social robot and
you know a lot of times we could ask the
question still today does it matter that
it's physically embodied does it matter
that it's a robot ironically I would say
when we first started this field we
would get papers just rejected from Kye
point-blank just because it was on a
robot and reviewers would say things
like why is it a robot it's so expensive
why not just think it a virtual agent so
the thing that we had to compete with
against was basically a screen with the
with a virtual avatar now we're having
defend ourselves against smart speakers
and I'm kind of like that seems like a
huge several steps backwards you're
taking even more impoverished stimulus
and you're asking us to vote on that so
again I guess that's just a lesson and
kind of combating ubiquity right once
are ubiquitous then suddenly you don't
have to fight these battles anymore but
we get asked this question a lot so what
is it what is it about the social code
presences it actually really matter so I
want to present work as a kind of a case
study in work that we've been doing in
Pediatrics this is a long-standing
collaboration with Boston Children's
Hospital where we've been working with
Child Life specialists and Child Life
specialists are professionals who are
trained to address the emotional support
and needs of children patients we're in
the hospital but also that of their
families and the question of course is
not surprising a lot of these domains
there are not enough Child Life
specialists to to meet the demands
the patient admitted patients and so the
question of how can you create a
different kind of technology that is an
extension of the Child Life Services
team that helps them basically do their
job in a more scalable effective way is
actually really really interesting and
I'd also say another kind of a side
effect of that is also how can you
extend that quality of care to the home
because you can maybe provide
exceptional quality of care in the
hospital but they need to be able to
continue to engage patients at home and
they have no way of doing that so so
again the notion of a robot of the
different kind of technology to do that
is really really interesting to them so
this is just a video that was done by
the New York Times kind of giving you a
little bit of color on on what this
looks like a piece of like this is not a
chronic condition she's gonna be in and
out of the hospital she's here for
procedures she's here for doctor's
visits she's missing school she's
missing her friends she's really not
doing any of the things that a normal
kid is doing and what we want to offer
kids like that is just one more way of
helping them to feel okay where they are
in what's otherwise a really stressful
experience I think there's a way of
connecting with kids that's different
from what grown-ups can offer they have
incredible imaginations and they can
really suspend disbelief and there can
be it's a relationship that develops
between huggable and a patient
[Music]
it's very nice to meet you do you want
to play again alright so what we have
here in this case is that we just
finished a clinical trial we have a
Child Life Specialist who works in the
room with one of three interventions so
we compared the physical robot versus as
as kind of plug compatible graphical
version of a robot on tablet versus
standard of care is a plush the social
agents is tele operated by another Child
Life Specialist there's a lot of reasons
why we do that one is just because we
want to make sure that the quality of
care is present we also want to collect
a lot of data to understand what is the
phenomenon of having a robot in this
kind of context that we can then think
about what are the AI is what are the
the opportunities to create more
autonomy for this so we often start
projects with this sort of teleoperation
paradigm to begin with we get a lot of
insights from that so we just finished a
clinical trial comparing these three
interventions which I think one of the
things that's nice about this study is
the Child Life specialists in the room
is doing her job to the best of her
ability with each of these interventions
and so in many ways all three of them
are socially animated whether that's a
remote trial life specialist tele
operating the virtual bear or the
physical bear or if it's even the Child
Life Specialist kind of puppeteering the
plush with the child right so all three
of these are animate one way or another
so you know we looked at the difference
between these technologies across a lot
of different dimensions where we were
particularly interested in the social
emotional factors if you're going to try
to create a technology intervention that
can engage children and improve their
pop you know their emotional experience
we are very interested in looking at
that we were interested in looking at
engagement how often children would
speak because if you want to engage a
child in a sort of
health protocol in the hospital their
engagement cooperativeness is very
important so if you look at these
different charts that what we see is you
know for things like total joyful
semantic effective analysis sentiment
analysis on the utterances that the
children would speak over time we see
that the positive effect increases over
time with the physical robot but it even
decreases over time with the the virtual
robot and the plush is kind of the
lowest when we look at shared attention
so the ability for a child to be not
only engaged in the technology with the
other people in the room you can imagine
for a Child Life Specialist this is
important you don't want the child just
having their face in the tablet we say a
lot more joint shared attention when you
have the physical robot there when you
look at just the amount of utterances
you see children are talking more over
time and we're seeing that with the
robot over in the avatar of the plush
and we see that the cooperativeness is
also high with the robot as well as the
avatar and then when you look at these
other social attributes like the
effective touch the social touch you
know people may be throwing the plush
across the room they may be poking the
tablet with this robot all of the touch
is a social relational touch and I think
you see that's in the video again and
again again so you know in the hospital
the conditions are actually they talk
about emotion as the fourth vital sign
and they say this is so critical because
we have all this equipment to measure
all these other biometrics of the child
but the emotional state of the child
affects everything from the recovery
rates to their compliance to even how
long it may take a child to give you
their arm to be able to give them a shot
for instance so they're very very very
interested in trying to come up with new
technologies to continually monitor this
and engage children in new ways we've
been looking at the opposite side as
well so it's another example of kind of
this emotional lift situation it was
lonely for people that's especially true
with the elderly but Kron 4s Maureen
Kelly discovered that some cornices of
looking communities here in the Bay Area
are finding camaraderie and fellowship
through robots
hey Jim okay you dance let me put on my
dancing shoes that was wonderful
Roger is a adavi technology right now is
me a new regular visitor here it's a
robot called Gebo that's being used as
part of a pilot project among the
several Bay Area facilities run by Elder
Care Alliance in addition to dancing it
can play the radio on request
now photograph oh that's it so what's
the plot for the skills tell jokes what
did the snail say when he was writing on
the turtle's back we and react to the
human touch it purrs what petted he also
often has some quirky responses to
questions hey G Bo what are you I am a
robot but I'm not just a machine I have
a heart well not a real heart but
feelings well not real feelings you know
what I mean
Aeryn Partridge a researcher and art
therapist when Elder Care Alliance takes
G Bo with her when she meets with the
seniors
she says this is not a case of
caretakers being replaced by automation
instead they are using this cute piece
of technology to encourage their
residents to connect with each other
despite some needing different levels of
care so when we have something that all
of us are experiencing all together
maybe for the first time right meeting a
robot you've got a focus point where we
can all meet right here in this moment
and have an interaction then it breaks
that down right it doesn't matter that
this person has dementia or this person
maybe has Parkinson's and have some
trouble talking we're all meeting
together as humans and robots Gebo
inspired some giggles and Capas amongst
this group here
well you get this age you should be able
to learn more and more what it does it
brings that out of us that's part of the
miracle of it
and that's part of the miracle of living
far as that goes welke so that was very
pointed for me so again it's about this
emotional lift of engagement that's just
very different from how engage with
other technologies but it goes even
beyond emotion so again if you look at a
number of these systemic comparative
studies comparing a physical robot to
even a video of a physical robot so you
know it's real but it's just not right
in front of you - a graphical agent of
the robot tuned disembodied voice what
we see is often these robots actually do
quite well so if you look at all these
interpersonal dimensions that lead to
kind of social judgments that have a
an effect on people's acceptance and
engagement of these technologies the
robots core quite well across trust
effect attraction empathy engagement
persuasiveness all of these kinds of
things so again there's something
actually very important going on about
the physical embodiment of this kind of
technology that she's engaging people
more deeply in a different kind of way
so the second theme I want to touch on
is again this notion now of this
collaborative Allied engagement and how
that's enabled with not just his voice
interface but this kind of interpersonal
UI this richly multimodal interpersonal
at UI and thinking about you know beyond
just interface to sort of building this
working alliance and building this sense
of rapport which again when you
collaborate with someone who's an
empathetic other that's very different
than a useful tool that you're using and
we know from human social psychology
right I mean we've been developing these
learning companions for children for
about five years now there's a lot of
social outcomes and you can look at as
well as educational outcomes and they're
all kind of tied to again this the
social engagement between people and
other people but now in this case people
and robots so again just appreciating
there's there's a holistic kind of
wrapper if the nature of engagement
directly impacts things like learning
attentiveness attitudes and so forth so
you know we do a lot of data collection
right so you know there's a lot of
excitement right now about deep learning
and you know there's certain kinds of
data sets that are vast and you can
label them but there's a lot of
important data sets that frankly don't
exist and these kinds of data sets that
are richly multimodal don't exist and we
think about underrepresented populations
like young children there's a dearth of
data around this so this is just kind of
a little montage to show you a little
bit about our process so if you want to
design a robot and engage in this
nonverbal dance while engaging children
in a story showing telling experience we
collect the data of what it's like to
see children actually tell stories to
one another we run various algorithms to
do automatic effective computing and
pose and all that kind of tracking and
then we use that to basically trying to
develop these computational models by
which we want to base the
embed that model now in a robot put it
in the same context with a child and see
how well does that model perform is the
model actually really capturing the
interaction that you saw with the two
children right so we do a lot of this
kind of work and these nonverbal cues
and the synchronous II and the
contingency turns out to be very
important for how children engage and
see the credibility of the robot as an
informative other to learn from so again
all these social judgments come along
with this that's really important for
engaging the children as a learner so I
want to just quickly touch on one
project that I think you know from this
video really highlights this different
way of engaging a technology right so
this is a learning companion take a
robot we design a series of educational
games this particular game is called
word quest the child in the robot they
play the game collaboratively so the
robot actually plays the game with the
child as they take turns there's a
challenge word presented that's you know
a pretty hard word for preschooler
like crimson or garment or something
like that and their task is to go
through pan through these story scenes
and trying to click on objects that
match that challenge word and what I
just want you to kind of notice from
this interaction is based on
reinforcement learning system to learn a
policy of engagement how these other
aspects of the collaboration are coming
out of this encounter we are trying to
find lavender color stuff
[Music]
all right so there was a moment in here
where you could hear the robot express
confidence her I'm sure you'll do better
next time I believe in you if you heard
her say very quietly she mirrored that
back to the robot so this is another
really important phenomenon we're seeing
is when as an AI engages people
certainly children in this case but we
see it across different generations as
an empathetic other you get all other
kinds of aspects of social modeling and
so in this case the child was modeling
empathy and a growth mindset back to the
Machine right so you know as a socially
influenceable technology this is this is
this is something that is definitely
something we need to really understand
we're using it or trying to benefit
children but of course this is something
we that could be applied to not benefit
children right so again just to say
there's a lot of ethics and a lot of
things we need to understand about this
work what's actually happening is that
we're applying reinforcement learning to
figure out a policy by which the robot
decides whether it should play the role
of an expert where it may be defining
the word for a child being able to
reinforce demonstrate its understanding
of why an object matches a word or a
novice whereby the robot may ask the
child questions the robot may make a
mistake on purpose and NASA child why it
made the mistake we basically compared
based on these three reinforcement
learning models always being an expert
always being a novice or this adaptive
roller switches between the two
being at children in the Boston Public
Schools we recruited schools especially
with kids with high ESL populations they
played this collaborative game where
they learn five words in the first
session turn-taking and then six of
these challenge words in the second
session you can see the challenge where
it's here they're things like Azur and
gigantic and stuff and they're just
silly we can see that benefit of having
this adaptive role so it's actually
better for the robot to not always be
the expert what we actually find is that
the chat if the robots always an expert
are always a novice children actually
start to kind of not pay attention but
when the robot keeps switching it up
more like an actual peer like companion
world they notice when the robot makes
the mistake they engage more and notice
when the robots asking you question they
answer right so again understanding this
role in the relationship and now that
impact children's not only engagement
even the learning outcomes here is
really interesting and what we find is
that children who even scored the lowest
on the preset pretest had the largest
gains from these two sessions with the
robots so again this is just a single
shot procession of these words with the
pre and post-test after and a delayed
post-test you know I could imagine that
of course if you had repeated sessions
like this complementing that in the home
children would score very very high on
this this sort of challenge level and we
think about you know kind of rules of
thumb of game design there's usually
this kind of 8020 rule of mastery things
you already know versus the new
challenge words all of these words are
hard and the fact that children engage
through all of them in stores as well I
think this is something that's worthy
I've got the further further
understanding of it through this
relationship can you actually have
children accelerate their learning
challenge them harder because they have
this empathetic other than if they just
play the game by themselves for instance
right so these are the kinds of
questions we're trying to understand and
dig into but again very promising very
exciting when you think about this
different kind of engagement the last
thing I want to touch on is
personalization so the promise of AI is
that live with you can learn about you
can optimize their behaviors to achieve
a learning outcome
this is another project that's around
early literacy language learning and
this is just to say how important this
is right so you're noticing a lot of
work we're doing engaging young children
you know the reason is there's just too
much data showing that if children don't
even start kindergarten
ready to learn it's very very very hard
to catch up so right now in this country
60% of children do not attend a quality
preschool and 37% of 12th graders in
can't even rate read a tour but the
proficiency level for their grade now
when you think about the future of the
workforce do you know a single scientist
or engineer who can't read at grade
level right and so the concern and the
worry of course is that dyes getting
cast way too early in a child's life so
you know people like Benjamin bloom
found this to sigmah effect that argues
being able to learn at your own pace to
be able to demonstrate mastery before
you move on having one-on-one
personalized sessions is the most
effective way to learn the problem is
it's not scalable and it's not
affordable right but with AI that can
change right so this is another example
now of learning oral language and
vocabulary with a second language or
with a early literacy robot where the
robot engages with children over a
period of three months so now we're
moving into long-term interaction of
repeated encounters where the robot is
learning a personalized model to each
child the robot engages in a relational
fashion we've been developing new
measures of how you measure this
relationship between children in the
robot and how that affects learning
efficacy the robot learns their name
refers to them by name cups about past
interactions talks about future
interactions and it's a story telling
story telling and story we sharing
paradigm where the robot tells a story
ask questions sis dialogic question
asking so we know and how parents tell
stories to children this dialogic
question asking is critical for the best
learning efficacy for children so the
robot engages in this way ask the child
to retell a story we capture a ton of
data we're capturing everything the
child says
she's wearing for census were
charactering biometric data or capturing
her facial expressions across all of
these kids to create a very rich corpus
of data that we're trying to basically
learn through reinforcement learning
again a model by which the robot can
predict of this library corpus of 72
stories that we can level by complexity
what is the optimal next story for the
robot to tell the child to promote the
vocabulary and their oral language
development
right so that's that's the task at hand
so this is just some data showing that
these are this is the confusion matrix
showing that the system is definitely
current learning a different policy per
child the models aren't converging yet
but the question is does this actually
impact the learning outcomes right so if
you look at measures of the oral
language gains we look compared the
personalized policy versus a non
personalized we see an accelerated rate
at which children are developing new
oral syntactic categories and again we
see big differences in vocabulary gains
between the personalized robot versus a
non personalized web which is still
again over baseline right so again a lot
of promise when we think about
innovation of new technologies that
engage different demographics different
diversity of needs around these kinds of
technologies that are really designed in
a way to try to match the way this
particular demographic learns and engage
is right I think that's that's the big
punchline so when we look at this kind
of work and we think about the bigger
bigger bigger bigger picture there is a
real opportunity to think about and we
hear this again and again when we gauge
our stakeholders we can provide
exceptional quality of care in our
institutions what we can't do is
continue that and engage it at home and
yet if you could do that you would have
much better outcomes for for their
stakeholders right so whether it's
education you learn at school how do you
continue that at home with an effective
personal tutor for whatever the subject
matter is when you talk about you know
an assisted living facility they will
tell you point-blank we cannot build
enough facilities to to meet the the
silver tsunami that's coming our way we
have to be able to engage people in
their homes as they age in place we
think about chronic disease management
help and we're on the same story but
even when we talk about high-touch
trimming counters there's a lot of
interest around a technology that can
engage people in this humanistic way so
whether you're talking retail our
hospitality etc etc there's a whole
wealth of possibilities and
opportunities for a technology that can
engage people in this humanistic
personalized high-touch way that we're
just starting to craft scratch the
surface so the last thing I want to talk
about is a comparative study to my
knowledge this is the first study of its
kind where we compared a digital
assistant talking speaker kind of
transactional AI in the home as it is
today with this sort of relational AI
social robot we use G Bo because it's
the one social robot out there that
actually has the features and functions
that we can actually do a comparison
with something like Alexa so people are
starting to live with social robots too
and you know the pictures that people
are sharing with social robots look a
little different than I think the
pictures people share it with Alexa
people are definitely engaging with this
technology and they talk about it as
being like one of the family which again
I think is is quite quite different so
different kind of AI different model
different kind of bias and how it's
designed how do these different
generations from children to adults to
older adults live with these different
kind of voice based agents in the home
and what are the implications for how we
should design these technologies what
are people's preferences what are their
boundaries so you know this is just a
fun video that just kind of highlights
the difference in the design stance of
these different technologies so tell me
about it
an Amazon's Alexa designed around your
voice I can provide information music
news weather and more Edie buh tell me
about your thumb okay sure
my name is G Bo I'm a robot my favorite
things to do are talking to people and
dancing I also really like Abraham
Lincoln because he was so honest and
because I like his hat okay good luck
tell me about yourself
I'm your Google assistant we can play
mad libs I can tell you a joke or you
can spin a wheel once you're okay okay
so again just to highlight different
design philosophies behind these
technologies now when we do this
comparison I mean it's nice and that
each of these technologies has offerings
in each of these categories from the
functional kind of utilitarian skillsets
to entertainment things like music and
games to social companion which could be
things like jokes greetings asking the
Asian about itself right they all have
offerings in all of these things they're
just weighted differently right we
actually had people do a personality
test for these agents and of course you
can see people actually attribute very
different personality profiles to
something like Gebo versus something
like Alexa where Alexa is seen as more
conscientious consistent and predictable
Gebo is seen as being more open more
extroverted and there's more empathy and
emotive nasaw obviously in the team
experience they're actually quite
similar in agreeableness so again this
is just to say different design
philosophies different emphasis and the
features and functions so we did a two
phase study we did a study where we
first brought people in before they
interacted with the agent these people
had not experienced or had an agent like
an Alexa orgy at home and we had them
look at what their kind of perceptions
and attitudes of features and functions
would be before they lived with the
agent then we said either half that
people got an Alexa or half the people
got a G both they lived with the agent
for a month and then we looked at
differences in engagement and difference
in perceptions about how that would
change after living with the agents of
the kinds of roles and features and
functions they thought they
after the fact we looked at children
which we defined as 15 to 5 to 17 years
old in our sampling pool call it younger
adults adults 18 to 49 and then older
adults 50 years and up right so these
are the three demographics we looked at
and this is a rough distribution so you
can see that you know when our older
adults you know a lot of them were more
like 50s and early 60s but we had one 98
year old and she was awesome okay so
this just gives you a sense of the
distribution of age profiles so you know
when we did our initial kind of cultural
probes and needs finding we had all
these cards with all these different
features and functions that you know if
you were going to have an agent like
this what would you want it to do and we
had people put these colored chips on
the cards that basically indicated
preferences which is like I would like
these things and I definitely would not
like these things right so this is all
about first impressions right and you
know this was fascinating right so we
look at children and adults and then we
look at older adults older adults were
the most open to the broadest range of
features and functions adults were the
pickiest I wouldn't have expected that I
would have thought that the older adults
would have been the most conservative
but they were the most open and this is
to say in these different categories of
things like reminders and information
and suggestions agent sharing something
as a proactive agent something it thinks
is interesting versus somebody trying to
reach you kind of mediating social
interaction or somebody through social
media sharing something we see that you
know if there's a lot of nuance here
right so the red is things that people
didn't think they want clearly
suggestions were the most kind of
polarizing kind of topic area but it
depended on what the agent was sharing
you know reading writing kind of things
like that's sharing something new people
were open to but they didn't want the
robot letting to know they should take a
nap right they didn't want the sense of
their autonomy being being kind of
challenged by this kind of agent but
again if you look at the different
generations here you see the older
adults are the most open to a whole
range of features and functions across
these categories that was fascinating
now we had people take very detailed
logs over the first 14 days we didn't
ask them to take logs at the second
13 days so what we did over the 1 month
is we track detailed usage in the first
14 even by just the color distribution
of these two plots you see something
very interesting right
here's Alexa with younger adults this is
G Bo with older adults right it's like
the flip really fascinating and then
when you look at kind of a five-day
running average we see these trends of
usage over time which we're also really
fascinating so it seems that the younger
adults want to anchor their usage first
in the utility and if you deliver enough
utility they'll start to use these kind
of social these kind of companionship
entertainment things later right whereas
children and seniors were the opposite
children mostly wanted entertainment but
if you couldn't anchor it in the social
and emotional for both children and
seniors you didn't get as much usage
overall in the utility right so children
were around the social entertainment and
older adults were even more right so
again this is fascinating to me in
particular because this is where the
social robotics is really coming through
right it's not as if Alexa didn't have
social entertainment functions but there
is something about the way their robot
did and arguably you could say Alexa had
many more social and entertainment
functions 10,000 30,000 skills right but
there's something about the nature and
the quality and the engagement that was
different enough that really got the
traction between the older adults and
and and the children now if you look at
the change in these different categories
over time of what people after the one
month what they thought they wanted we
see that suggestions is even more
polarizing right so that's to say that
you may have a stakeholder pool where
suggestions like medication reminders
and things are actually really important
but this is to say that the way you do
them I think actually really matters the
groups or the functions that had the
most positive change what people wanted
more of were these socially driven
categories right so although I'd say in
a lot of these systems right now there's
a lot around utility after living with
these ages for a month these socially
driven categories were the most kind of
that's what people wanted more right and
then we had this injury
in construct called the wish jar so we
had these little wooden tokens that at
any point during the 30 days you could
write a little thing about what you want
the robot to do or agent to do what you
didn't like whatever just some sentiment
about the experience and we collected
them and when you look at Alexa you see
kind of a consolidation of topics around
a lot or unfunctional somewhere around
humor and they want to Lex have a better
sense of humor
some around movement and then some
around proactivity but interestingly
when you looked at the social robot
people's expansiveness in terms of what
they wanted this agent to do and fit in
their life was much more diverse so
that's fascinating right it's like this
is a much more narrow categorization of
how they see this agent fitting their
life the robot potentially has a lot
more Headroom and where it can go so
again just fascinating stuff so the last
thing I want to talk about now is this
bigger societal question of who creates
with AI right we're talking about people
living with AI we're talking about more
vulnerable populations living with AI
other institutions organizations are
building these AIS for these people but
when only a small fraction of a society
can design with these technologies
almost by necessity it's only going to
be applied to address the needs of a
small subset of society right there's
just going to be inherent bias there so
how do you democratize who creates with
AI for me it all gets down to education
so we're starting to look at AI
education for even starting at preschool
so K pre-k through 12 we're a sweet spot
right now is pre-k through like 12 years
old and the reason why is because when
you can have children first of all
they're living with these technologies
you want them to understand them
appreciate the way they think to be able
to feel the right relationship and
empowerment over them but you want
children growing up with an attitude
that AI is something that not only they
can understand but they can actually
create with and so we've been building
on top of the scratch platform adding
extension blocks to things like Watson
and clarify and hue lights and robots
like G Bo and Cosmo to empower children
to code these systems to train their own
models for these systems and then to put
those models and new experiences of
personal significance for them so this
is an example of an exercise the kind of
warm-up thing we have children do where
first they try to come up with a gorilla
more code in terms of what can we say to
make McCosker react to to what we said
and they realize kind of how like time
consuming and the instances are explicit
and then we invite them to do it with
something like a classifier system that
they can train right so this is just
getting their heads wrapped around how
two classifiers work why are they
interesting why won't you want this to
do it make it more generalizable and
then we have interfaces we're developing
that kids can actually come up with what
are the things I'd want to actually put
in the training set so you know having
Oscar be happy to kind of things you say
or having asked their assets acts add to
mean things but even kids wanted to
create backhanded compliments so they so
anyway so you see like the way kids are
thinking about these things is
fascinating it's so this is giving them
hands-on experience and to what it's
like to create these system so this is a
quick kind of summary video of the
platform it's again it's very much a
research project it's not just for kids
actually it's for families too because
parents have these things in their house
as well and they also need to understand
them and we're trying to understand how
to create experiences that parents and
kids can also do together so again it's
kind of the scratch blocks like
programming but you can see a diversity
of blocks right
there's clarify there Steve on this
Alexa so kids are being able to create
these custom IOT a experiences across a
big kind of palette of these AI based
technologies so we allow them to train
models
they didn't think people teach it's like
mind blown computer maximized colors so
like he's tagged and labeled those
colors here took a picture and label it
as green and so they're able to explain
how they're training these models and
that's important too right
[Music]
so again and you know through the
process of building these projects kids
are talking about how the systems work
how they need to train change the
training set why the models not right
yet they're able to work collaboratively
they're able to articulate their ideas
they're able to think creatively and
systematically so basically they're
learning a whole bunch of 21st century
learning skills as well which I think is
really critical so we have an
opportunity so last week I think was the
week that the computer science teaching
Association partnered with triple AI R
on AI education and you know there's
been a very grassroots the teachers
movements to bring computer science
education into k12
I think with that there's an opportunity
to bring AI education into k12 and to
really create the curriculum and
exercises from the ground up that's very
hands-on collaborative getting children
to tinker with this stuff to think about
this stuff and to build this 21st
century skills that we all want want our
kids to have so they have access to
these opportunities this incredible
opportunities and this time that we live
in and I think this is critical because
you know if we want truly humanistic AI
we need to empower a much greater
diversity of people to create these
oh geez right because it's people from
their different walks of life that have
the empathy and the appreciation of the
challenges and the opportunities that
matter to them in their communities so
whether it's creating relationally eyes
that's our support of the people in this
kind of personalized empathetic other or
whether it's these kinds of educational
initiatives that empower a much broader
diversity people to create with a eyes
kids as well as adults and I would argue
even seniors I think this is how we're
going to get to AI that can truly
benefit everyone and not just a few
alright so I'm gonna end there thank you
very much what are all the living video
yeah yeah so that was that layer rolling
to there be more open yeah so I think
what I mean again I think what you're
seeing from the in-home one month study
in general was I think the lesson to me
is older adults and seniors they do
understand that technology can help them
and empower them but it needs to be
designed in the right way so they're
open to it but you know there's a lot of
stuff that are designed for them that
isn't necessarily stuff they they want
to use so I think that was clear in the
assisted living facility where actually
the thing that was compelling was it was
a practitioner in the facility who had
the intuition that this technology could
enhance the way residents would engage
with one another so it was not replaced
and they made the point the story this
was not about replacing the
practitioners it was really about saying
if we introduce this other kind of
technology can we spur a richer
community collaborative connection among
the residents so that was the hypothesis
and that study is continuing to go on
I don't think it's because they're
lonely I think it's because they see
technology as something that can really
help help them it just needs to be
designed in the right way there's a
recent case where like Kidd for
mistreating Alexa and I think they added
in the new word please
Alexa is there anything about this
approach that might discourage or make
kids want to treat the agent more
respectfully well so I think you know
again we're in this very intriguing time
and especially with these social robots
where children are engaging them more
like another versus a device and what we
see is because of that children like
I'll give you an example so we we did a
study last year and we just did a launch
of tools that we're finishing up now
looking at children learn all kinds of
things from others you know there's kind
of this more curricular stuff there's
also things like attitudes like a growth
mindset fixed mindset versus growth
mindsets and children require mindset
based on how adults often or teachers
praise them and speak to them so if
parents and teachers reinforce that oh
you're so smart you know then the
concern is what happens when things get
hard do they assume like oh I'm just not
good enough anymore or if they appraise
effort and that's how you learn that's
the growth mindset right so we designed
a puzzle solving game where we had
children play the game with either a we
call it a neutral mindset robot cuz we
thought a fixed mindset would be
unethical a neutral mindset robot that
would just make factual comments about
the state of the game play versus a
growth mindset robot and what we found
was that the children who interacted
with a growth mindset robot
self-identified greater in the post
testing of having a growth mindset and
on the intentional parts of the task
where we challenged kids and actually
made them fail they tried harder and
they demonstrated more grit so and even
in that video I showed you where the
robot says I believe in you when she got
it wrong and you heard her say back to
the robot I believe in you we see this
social modeling phenomenon again and
again and again and
again I would say at this point I think
it's quite robust so and we're starting
to explore that phenomenon and empathy
you know can you actually have social
robust engaged children with you know a
known issue with bullying and to have
them become more empathetic so that's
just to say that engaging their
social-emotional Processing's and
behaving x' I think this is a technology
that clearly can do it it can be applied
I think to really help kids but then it
needs to be done in a really ethical
responsible way because clearly it you
know children are engaging those parts
of their brain when they're engaging
with this technology and I think it's
not just kids it's people of all ages so
yes I think it's important that these
technologies model the kind of behavior
that you want because I think it
actually helps reinforce the kind of
behavior we want to see in each other so
I think there's an opportunity there so
thinking about the transaction is a
social robot even in conversation system
systems it'd be very hard to pin down
good reward functions that reinforcement
learners can actually use so in the two
examples that you pointed out and
curious like how robust do you think the
remote functions better yeah I mean I
think I mean it's early days right so I
can say that what we are doing is we're
you know those inputs are going into the
reinforcement learning element something
is trying to optimize so we're looking
at effective computing inputs the
biometrics for engagement we're looking
at their responsiveness to the robots
dialogic questions we're looking at
whether they get things right or wrong
we're looking at their language samples
and so we're trying to both use
reinforcement learning to kind of
simultaneously maximize engagement as
well as these learning outcomes and
we're seeing promise I think that you
know these are early days I think that
the the point of showing the slides is
this hasn't been done for kids this
young first of all right I mean and and
and building a technology that addresses
these social-emotional nonverbal things
hasn't been done for kids like this
right so it's a chef the fact that you
couldn't even show boost on both the
dimensions is noteworthy and important
it's just to say there's probably a pony
in there right
a lot more work needs to be done and I
think that's you know that's kind of the
state of the field right now it's like
we're starting to see a different way of
engaging the human mind and behavior
that is actually I think quite profound
right this is no longer about
naturalness these are deep social
processes that this technology is able
to tap into right and so this is kind of
like this is not shallow this is
actually quite deep and we need to
understand it and we need to think about
how it can be leveraged to benefit
people we need to be able to create best
practices so it's not used to you know
obviously try to make people do
something that's to benefit a third
party and not the person themselves
right so it's just to say we live in
interesting times but we are seeing a
very kind of you know provocative
psychology happening here and again it's
it's it runs deep and I think the more
we do this work we're discovering how
deep it actually goes a lot of the
agents have this novelty effect like
about the Kip see I think I'm super
excited and it is hard to make it
permanent like me of this longer-term
friendship what have you talked about
this continued engagement how you can
actually form folds then and go beyond
the problem absolutely so I mean I think
you can see in a number of these studies
they're longitudinal so they're going
well beyond the kind of novelty effect I
actually think in our field we need to
have a real deep systematic
investigation of what we mean by the
novelty effect because you know when I
was first a graduate student it was like
a five-minute encounter before you
started the task was enough to address
the novelty effect now it's like two
weeks or you haven't addressed the
novelty effect so we just need to be
much more rigorous and what we mean when
we say the novelty effect that said you
know when you're interacting with the
system over three months or a month
every day in the home you're past the
novelty effect so it's a combination of
things I do think you know there is
definitely you need enough freshness in
the activities or it's like no matter
how compelling Angry Birds is it's going
to get boring at some point so you need
enough variability and freshness of the
activities
sustained any sort of encounter I think
these relational things are also really
important so the fact that the robot
whether it's Deva or take are actually
doing these social grooming functions
greeting you in the morning asking you
how your day was remembering that
personalizing that to you commenting on
did you have another good night's sleep
or I'm sorry I hope you sleep better lap
tomorrow night did you sleep better
tonight I mean these things matter and I
guess that's we're finding it's the
personalization combined I think with
the again the support of empathetic
other actually matters to people so I
think it's a combination of those things
and there's other things as well I mean
I think but you know we're at the very I
think beginning of understanding how you
design for sustained relationship and
you're starting to see mechanisms we're
exploring here it's hard to do this work
it's hard to deploy these systems that
like these robot systems in people's
homes for a long period of time to
collect the data it's just hard it's
logistically hard and expensive to do
but it's important work that needs to be
done so you know it's just to say
there's a lot of opportunity here I
think and and very poignant but just
like interpersonal interaction I think
there's a whole set of processes that
are at play to build that sustained
sense of not only just engagement but
that kind of relationship that you feel
like you're actually working with the
other or for sustained period of time to
reach a goal of personal significance
and I think that's also part of it so
you know I thought your part about the
AI tutor was really really interesting
what are some of the next steps then you
see applications for the AI tutor given
the technology that we have right now
yeah so I mean obviously you know
computer tutors is a huge field I think
it tends to be applied more towards
older students and as ten seems to be
tended to apply to more towards like
math and physics and kind of stem
explicit stem areas we were going after
the younger you know early childhood
learning for a number of reasons one is
just it's a critical time to intervene
as I talked about
it's an under explored area for
technological innovation children at
that age just learned in a very
different way they absolutely learn from
friendly empathetic others that's how
they're wired to learn so you need to
design to support that I think there's a
whole host of things we need to address
around early childhood learning around
early math and literacy and even you
know the fastest growing demographic
entering our public schools our English
language learners which is why we are
going out to recruit from schools with
high English language learning
populations kids with special needs is
another huge area right so whether it's
attentional issues or ASD or whatnot
I think there's huge opportunities for
again kind of giving everyone the best
possible chance of being successful by
addressing a diversity of learners
that's where you know I think a lot of
high impact opportunity is on the flip
side I think you can look at workforce
retraining you know and with all that
kind of concern about AI replacing our
jobs I think there's a huge opportunity
for AI to actually retrain us for new
jobs so I think that could become a new
and another kind of huge impact area for
education there's a lot more discussion
around kind of lifelong learning as well
and continuing education so it's all
important you know but for me just after
looking at all of the data and all the
opportunity it's the early childhood
stuff you know the fact that the die is
being passed for way too many children
way too early in their life it's just
not right so I do think that's going to
be the biggest kind of social justice
area of intervention for education you
asked me yeah at one point you were
showing how people perceive the
personalities of Alexa and Bebo and I'm
wondering for Devo like how did that
match like the Intendant design of
juegos personality or is there anything
that surprised you there I think that
apps that did match I think the kind of
design stance of how would you but was
designed him and he's designed to be
open and extroverted and to you know
convey and elicit this emotive kind of
empathetic response we would like it if
he was perceived to be more
conscientious you know some of us just
she continues to improvement of all you
know but and he just doesn't you know he
doesn't have 10,000 skills yet you know
so so there's some of that at play as
well but in terms of you know I think
again the punch line for me of
especially that working average of
seeing the trends is to say that's where
the social robotics is really showing up
because Alexa has arguably more
offerings in all of those categories
than a product like giba that's only
been on the market a few months and yet
you see this different and engagement
that's the social robotics coming
through that's a different way that the
robot are showing up to people in their
lives that's leading to that engagement
you know I think this is something the
field or even in the consumer landscape
and corporations have you know have yet
to really grasp is that this is actually
it's this is different this kind of
experience is quite different and you
know it's appealing to a diversity of
users right that I think is also
noteworthy right so I think the punch
line for me is also if if younger adults
are keying in on utility that's just a
matter of time for social robots they're
done they have the skills to so at some
point that's going to be mood and then
it really is about these are other
aspects you know it is about this other
relational AI aspects and that
technology to me to me that says that in
the long run
social robotics are going to be the next
thing right because you can't just
always be disembodied talking speakers
right clearly that's going to be the
glide path and we're starting to see it
in this engagement data and again it
just gets down to the way we are our
brains work you know we are we evolve to
want to connect and relate to animate
entities in this way and you know the
more you designed to support that the
richer the engagement right so I think
that's it's not surprising when you
think about it that way but I think the
industry has to kind of catch up I think
right now our spoken language systems
are very much like playing chess it's
like discrete turns but communication
human communication is it's a dance it's
it's not playing chess it's it's
mutually regulated it's dynamic its
fluid it's it's all of these things and
that's where all of these other things
like liking and trust in
come to play so your lunch and I'm I'm
just maybe this is projecting way too
far in the future but I remember reading
an article where it was said that dogs
have been bred to the point where they
prefer the company of human to the
company of dogs and so it's not that far
stretch to think that eventually the
social robot will be socially far
superior to other humans and thence
humans may start preferring the company
of robots to the company of humans and
how far in the future do you think that
is we have already observed so so I yeah
so I will say this people need people we
need to feel that we belong to our
community we need to feel valued by our
community that our community cares about
us we can't flourish if we don't have
that and so I think these robots and
these intelligent technologies are going
to be you know a wonderful augmentation
of society but people still will always
need people and these technologies
should be designed to enhance and
support that you know I'm not sure to
get your premise I mean it's certainly
no truthful dogs well but I'm not
talking about the dog I'm talking about
what it is to be human
humans need humans I'm not saying dogs
can't be bred to prefer humans over dogs
I'm saying the way human beings are by
our very nature we are profoundly social
species right we've evolved to need you
know social pain is now being
appreciated to be real pain right it's
not just this kind of stiff upper-lip
thing it's it's processed in the same
regions of the brain as actual pain
we're just you know chronic loneliness
is a serious of a health condition and
smoking and obesity and substance abuse
it's like we're just starting to really
appreciate the neuroscience of how
deeply social we are so people need
people you're making good the premise of
what you're saying is based
the fact that we will never have more
empathy for robot one for us is that
correct
I think that human relationships are
complex and messy and important and they
make life worth living I I do there's
something about the human human
relationship that I don't think you're
going to be able to replace with the
machine I don't think you can't create
machines they're going to help benefit
people and profoundly important ways but
I don't think they're going to replace
what's important about the human
connection to people and I'm you know
I'd be willing to say I think the
neuroscience is gonna show that we refer
to the science social robotics have some
problems with social skills so you know
I think like all aspects of robots you
can probably put you know a panel of
experts on social robotics and probably
give you different definitions of what a
social robot is just like they're gonna
give you definition different
definitions of what a robot is so they
absolutely have social skills I would
say it's beyond that though it's that if
they are they are engaging it's how they
engage people right they are engaging
these social thinking reasoning
mechanisms of a person would it be fair
that they operate in a way in a form of
social engineering I don't know I don't
understand a form of social engineering
I mean they're manipulation through the
simulation of social or human life
social skills so I would say that
absolutely so as they are designed the
human mind engages with them in a way
that we've evolved to be and you can
design these systems to use that to
benefit people Patrice's comment Wilson
so for us there's the danger of
manipulating or plasticity so the
question is there was this video about
you know that he wasn't the the ledger
the the a selfish ledger that Google
released so far who is motivating the
social robots to do this is this like
the nor behalf this is this is what this
is what's so important to discuss yes so
whether it's virtual reality and
people's
sisters being stimulated like it's the
real thing or whether it's advertising
or cinema we're not strangers to
artifacts manipulating us right we do
this all the time in many many different
capacities our games are advertised I
mean this is not the new new thing it's
just to say that it can happen here as
well and we need to understand it and we
need to have dialogues around best
practices and you know how it should be
implied to benefit people because
clearly the good news here is that it
can really benefit people but you don't
want unintended consequences I love your
saying this because this is a very
perhaps subtle atomic bomb so you can
say let's let's have children interact
with robots that are experts in social
engineering go so having that running
without concern of people that usually
would be dangerous or and I would say
like any time you're trying any form of
learning right designing and a serious
game right I mean this is just what this
is is a different dimension of designing
technologies that interface with the
human mind and behavior right that's
that's that's what all of this is
essentially about right and it's to say
you know just like too much green timing
right now people are willing to say that
screens can be adduct addictive to kids
right
it's to say eyes wide open with any
technology with any age group I wouldn't
say it's just kids with any age group
tremendous benefit as possible but you
got to keep eyes wide open absolutely so
you you wanted to ask a question the
chance how did you measure benchmark
empathy on they were like multiple shots
image empathy was showing oh so this was
literally like a personality test that
you would give to people that people
filled out for the agent so there was
like standard questions asked on a
personality test is what is what that
that represented so the people who
measured anybody based on their
interstices so people were asked a
question like here's the set of
questions how would you rate the agent
just like if you are taking a
personality test for yourself fill it
out for yourself they were doing that
for the agent
here's a set of questions how would you
fill it out so that that's what that was
generated from it is literally like a
personality test but just applied people
applied it to the agent here's have you
noticed maybe an analogy with the
uncanny valley with social interactions
like have people kind of recoiled like
that's too realistic or kind of been
weird yes the uncanny valley I think
it's something that you know people
throw that term out a lot really what it
means is the more human-like something
becomes you go into this kind of you
know feels creepy kind of factor so I
think in for me a more recent example is
you know human animated characters in
film at the time of like the first tin
toy Pixar I don't remember the baby in
the concrete diaper way in the valley
way in the valley but then at some point
you know Shrek whatever clearly we could
just tell that it wasn't a real human
but the aesthetic was out of the valley
right so something as abstract as Gebo
isn't really something that's going to
fall in the valley because it's it's
it's meant to be
how exactly human-like it looks is kind
of what that conjectures really about
but I would say that when you ask people
you know creepy creepy can mean any
number of things to people could mean
creepy because it seems so lifelike to
another person would make it seem really
cool right and then there's kind of
creepy like walking corpse creepy which
is you know that's what the uncanny
valley I think was really getting on one
more when do you think G Bo will get
arms and legs like like as yes yeah like
we have all these Alexa's speakers that
are stationary but yeah you suppose so I
would say you know when people ask me
what a social robot is a social robot is
not something that only sits in your
countertop I happen to build those
systems because I want to focus on the
social but I would argue Baxter is a
social robot because it was designed to
work collaborative at the person and
it's got the screen with the eyes and
the attention it's a social
manufacturing robot so you know Toyota
research other people are going to
create mobile manipulator social
robots because they have to live with
people and it's that social
interpersonal confidence that's going to
be critical for it fitting into people's
lives and then wanting to have it around
and for it to actually being
collaborative and helpful so you know I
just think it's you know it's all it's
all gonna happen okay come you okay yeah
I thought it was interesting that the
the interaction was sort of better when
the robot switch from being expert to
novice because I think a lot of us do
like robot as a student or robot as a
teacher but sort of doing that but how
did you decide what exactly an expert or
novice meant because I think the way we
interact with each other and there's
different there's a good graded scale of
they're an expert now we're anonymous
yeah there were specifically different
behaviors that the robot would do in
either role so a novice role the robot
may ask a question and the reason why
it's really asking the question is
because it wants a child to articulate
because that's gonna help them learn but
it's playing the role of the novice or
in the novice role the robot would
intentionally make a mistake and ask the
child why do you think that was wrong so
like those are examples of like novice
behaviors after expert behaviors would
be things like you know giving the
definition of the word or giving the
child a hint right so so in this
particular implementation there were
just different kinds of behaviors the
robot would do in one role or the other
and we used reinforcement learning plus
some adaptation to switch the roles
dynamically based on you know how the
child was doing both from a kind of
effective computing standpoint as well
as their actual performance in the game
right so the robot was always you know
making decisions based on how do i best
support this child in this moment even
as it was kind of taking this different
kind of role but what we definitely saw
anecdotally was children Kaunas you know
what they're kind of they became a
little more of a Leanback experience and
when the robust behavior was predictable
and it always kind of took one role the
other whereas when it was mixing it up
they noticed more and and what we also
found again the social modeling thing is
the more the robot talks about its own
process the more children talk out loud
about their process so we see this
social modeling half
again and again in so many different
constructs and in this case it's you
know obviously done in a way to promote
the children's learning because the more
they articulate and reflect and
verbalize the more likely they are to
actually learn these things right so in
each role art is the robot learning what
just stay because I could imagine like
in the future to have some sort of like
hobby so it's not it's not it's not
learning on the fly you know how to
generate I mean there's a set of kinds
of parameterised utterances it's going
to say so it's kind of more templatized
of these forums in the future yeah you
can imagine having that be much more
flexible but in the case of this
particular work it was more templated
kinds of responses okay good thank you
guys thank you
[Applause]